everybody is Charlie surprise Rick and
Morty music video original animation
dropped to announce the big festival
that they're doing this October
headlined by run the jewels they're not
the only people that are performing so
I'll explain what's going on with the
festival because they'll be showing off
previews for everything they haven't
announced any official statements about
Rick and Morty season 4 stuff or when
work is going to start and most of the
stuff that Dan Harmon has been posting
has been him slowly losing weight on his
Instagram but I do have some audio of
him drunkenly reviewing Thor Ragnarok
and some of the Marvel vs. DC movies
which is fantastic but 99% of you
probably picked up on the pulp fiction
theme of this music video so we'll call
this the pulp fiction dimension just
because the groffle mites are dressed up
like they're inside a Quentin Tarantino
movie and normally you just see them
dressed up in governmental uniforms or
soldiers uniforms they sort of use the
mega seeds planet from the pilot episode
so you never actually find out what's in
that final briefcase we'll talk about
that in a second but really the twist of
this is the briefcase within a briefcase
like they get that first briefcase and
it turns out to be the small grandpa
mine I was disappointed when they
actually showed you what was in the
briefcase until the end of the video
when you find out that that's not the
real thing that they were going for so
he grows the Grandpa bite just so that
he can interrogate it and find out where
the real Pulp Fiction briefcase is I
don't know which of the Rick and Morty
people animated this but there are a
couple backgrounds that are a little bit
different from those on the show so it
might not have been someone from the
Rick and Morty crew to do it they might
have just completely stylized this just
for the music video because you look at
Rick's wall here and it's a little bit
different than the wall that you would
see in a traditional episode here's my
big question for you guys though what do
you think is in Rick's briefcase like
obviously it's meant to be a MacGuffin
just like Quentin Tarantino's parody hi
Jean Rizzo I get just implies something
of value but usually the things that
Rick values end up being Monday like
Szechuan sauce or clack sea and crystals
or something funny so that's why you're
never meant to know what's in there like
it's just meant to be a parody but
here's my other big question for you
guys let me know in the comments Rick
and Morty bust in here who is Sam
Jackson and who's John Travolta my first
instinct was to say that Rick would
probably be
Sam Jackson just because he's so much
more hardcore than John Travolta's
character but you guys decide in the
comments the deal with the festival
though is that it's happening in
downtown LA they're calling like the
first big Adult Swim music festival but
that's really what it's meant to be a
giant music festival with a bunch of
other stuff happening so they say
they're gonna have previews for the
shows they'll be comedy performances so
it does sound like it'll be pretty big
but it's October 6th and 7th you can buy
tickets on the Adult Swim website and if
you buy the early bird passes for the
entire weekend with like every possible
parking pass and thing that you could
buy it winds up being a little over $300
so if you really like those Adult Swim
live events then I would recommend
checking it out like I've already bought
the early bird passes I think the prices
go up if you wait and it'll probably
sell out relatively quickly so if you do
have an interesting going I would
recommend you buy your tickets sooner
rather than later but as of right now
they haven't announced who the other
musical acts are going to be who the
comedy performers are going to be and
whether or not they're going to be doing
any original Rick and Morty stuff there
because they're using Rick and Morty to
sell this it's implied that there'll be
a lot of Rick and Morty stuff happening
speaking of ticket sales Marvel dropped
their infinity war trailer this morning
and announced that ticket sales were
available they broke the world wide
record for movie ticket pre-sales within
the first six hours like they blew right
past it in the previous record-holder
was marvel for the Black Panther movie
just a little while ago but speaking of
Marvel movies like I said Dan Harmon
drunkenly reviewing thor ragnarok this
is a little clip of him talking about
Marvel movies and then talking about
Marvel vs. DC so we'll just put a little
bit of this in here because he is kind
of drunk but it's him talking to Jessica
gal one of the other riders from Rick
and Morty season 3 on their new podcast
black panther what's up applause yeah he
can't like rip dimensions open with him
or anything
no but he could rip you apart well you
know the threaten me well I don't want
you to climb walls you know what yes he
can I finally saw Thor I was about to
ask no I mean it's a Marvel movie it's a
Marvel movie I got it I got I got news
for every kid listening and I know
Harmon doesn't like Marvin
you know what they're like it's like
yeah they're fine if they're good and
they're I'll if they're bad I don't
mention them I thought that Thor the
interesting thing about Thor is I didn't
it feel like we were like two braids of
that movie and one was like a very Tyco
ytt like yeah 80s inspired like yeah
totally like it was like there was this
amazing like kind of like linear
meandering adventure going on and then
there was like all this pipe that had to
be fulfilled with like this dumb story
about like someone's sister that wants
to take over the thing and it was like
kinda McKenna like one bank account kept
robbing the other that's what I felt
watching that movie I was like can we
just watch this movie that's like this
cool eighties psycho ITT movie about
Jeff Goldblum and like taking a prisoner
like yeah that was great always love
hearing Dan Harmon talk about
traditional comic-book movies especially
after episodes like The Vindicator 's
which give you an idea for how he feels
about 99% of those movies if you're
asking if they're gonna make fun of
infinity war or any of the other big
Avengers films that are coming out in
the next year during Rick and Morty
season four I feel like they kind of
already did that with Vindicator 'he's
like Vindicator x' is a direct send up
of the Avengers but as for brand new
season four stuff it sounds like it's
gonna be a while before we see any
season four news but we probably get
more small promos and music videos like
this like original Rick and Morty
animation so technically new but
probably not the new stuff that you're
really hoping for so whatever ends up
dropping I will totally do a video for
believe all your rick and morty video
requests in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe to get everything
click here for more new Rick and Morty
and click here to watch that new
Avengers trailer again a billion more
times thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]